this is a
a a great new day the first chapter
we will alternate between 15 minute and
10 minute i'm thinking
but uh
let's begin with
15
minutes and uh let's commence
game one here we go
[Music]
okay we got a game marcy p
okay definitely we play e4 that's for
sure
yeah so let's begin by playing the four
night scotch i i propose this opening as
as an initial opening because
essentially well first of all
in many of these games we're not even
going to get knight c6 and that problem
is going to be solved for us this is one
of those games queen f6 pretty common
move at this level
obviously it's bad
um for many reasons uh but the main one
is that black not only doesn't develop a
minor piece but
deprives the square of the g8 knight
and reacting to such openings is is a
lot easier than it seems
right and the first step in reacting to
them is generally to
actually get the advantage in
development and then you're going to
think about opening up the center so you
don't need to play d4 here
right let's just go knight c3 another
approach would have been pawn c3 and d4
but i like to play with the pieces at
this basic level
okay c6
already here i would think about going
d4 and opening up the center because
there's already an imbalance of two
developed pieces to zero
and obviously the queen gets vulnerable
in these types of situations so
oh yeah the timer is off let me just
adjust the timer
so this would be a great time
this would be a great time to play
d4 and i think that's what we're gonna
do
once i adjust the timer
okay
sorry about this
all right
so let's go d4
and let's open up the center all right
he takes d4
we take with the knight we could have
also played bishop g5 here but i'm
avoiding any complicated intermediate
moves bishop c5
um
what to do now
how should we proceed in this position
and yeah knight b3 would be an excellent
move yeah of course bishop b3 this is
kind of a an easy developing move that
also protects the knight i think a lot
of beginners here would be tempted to go
knight f3
um but
don't hesitate to defend a piece with
another piece this is one of the safest
ways of defending it to have a bishop on
the neighboring diagonal square
all right
so far we are
simply developing he goes d6
okay so let's take stock of what we
still need to develop we need to castle
one way or the other
and we need to develop our bishop from
f1
what in what order do we do things well
generally i like to develop the bishop
first because we could actually
potentially castle
a queen side
and i don't know which way we want to
castle i want to wait and see what black
does
that's one of the techniques for solving
the problem of where to castle so let's
start by developing the bishop well
where do we go
this square's out of the question it
blunders the knight bishop b2 is always
possible but to me bishop c4 is
going to be the most active move in
these cases
some of you might notice the the move b5
but then we'll just drop the bishop back
to b3
oh
knight h6 actually not a bad move
and already at this level you have to be
asking yourself uh what your opponent
wants and one of the
triggers for that is when your opponent
makes an unusual developing move whether
they develop the knight to the side of
the board
uh or some some weird move to the side
of the board something like that
you have to smell a rat because
oftentimes there's going to be some
hidden intention and if you look
carefully it's not that black wants to
play bishop g4 that's not dangerous
because then we just move our queen
i think that black wants to go knight g4
and that actually is dangerous because
then black threatens to ruin our pawn
structure and we can't move our bishop
because the knight is defended
now we have f3 and h3 and in 90 of cases
when you choose between these two moves
uh
you you generally want to choose
h3 and since we already pushed upon on
the king side
it does make a lot of sense here to play
queen d2
and castle queenside
because
not that castle and king's side would be
unsafe for our king
more so
that um this pawn and h3 can serve as an
anchor
for a further pawn that reaches g4
that's
the logic
all right so we have a tactic here
we have a tactic but it
it's very messy and i don't want to rely
on these things while we're still in the
beginner stage
so we're just going to drop the bishop
back
but i'll talk about this afterwards
knight a6 okay so this guy likes to
develop pieces to the side of the board
that doesn't affect us we castle
and now we are ready at last
to start attacking on the king side
you have opposite side castling oh we
could have also taken this pawn i didn't
even see yeah we can take it now
we can take the spot on c6 i didn't even
notice it
um the idea of bishop b6 is probably to
go c5 which itself is not very dangerous
remember that when pawns are pushed
there very often will be other pawns
that are left undefended
so just always ask yourself that as well
as squares
but i don't see any reason for us not to
take this pawn that's a free pawn
it chops the the legs completely off of
black's sort of pawn phalanx now this
hangs that hangs and we can start taking
stuff
many good moves in this position but
there is one move that
immediately appeals to me because it
attempts to squeeze the most out of the
position
um
a good move here would be to take the
pawn on d6
a bad move would be to play knight takes
b5 because that diverts the knights away
from the center and it gives away the e4
pawn but a really good move would be
knight d5 simply centralizing the knight
attacking the queen and
if you look more carefully you'll notice
that the queen simply doesn't have that
many good squares if he goes queen g6
there's a fork
queen e6 there is a discovery but what
black has to do is take the bishop first
and then go queen e6 these are only
moves
but even there
we've clearly achieved
a lot by getting this knight into such a
nice square okay queen g6
is a pretty common blunder at this level
does it matter which knight you put on
e7 no if you're already winning the
queen
and i see players doing this a lot
don't overthink winning moves
if you have two ways to deliver a fork
and you're winning a full queen it's
probably not going to matter you want to
compare the two moves quickly
but you don't want to sit there and
obsess over
you know minuscule
differences in two ways of winning a
queen they both win a queen
okay what to do now
we've talked many times on the speeder
and about techniques of converting an
advantage when you are up a queen
the best approach is oftentimes just
brute force
destroy your opponent's pawn structure
and the game
i would not take b6 actually
i would start by by looking at black's
king to see if we can't just win finish
winish finish the game
immediately and
you know if you look at that side of the
board you should see bishop takes h6
now don't think of this move as
g takes h6 queen takes h6 don't tie
yourself to that move always reassess
the situation
every time your opponent's king king
side has been weakened
right he's taken on h6 with a pawn which
means
that pawn used to be on g7
and immediately i see that this opened
up a diagonal we have checkmate queen c3
or queen d4 check doesn't matter i just
played queen c3 to
make sure that it wasn't on
you know on the path of the bishop
now the king walks right into
a secondary x-ray
now knight f6 is not checkmate common
blunder
making a double check or a discovery
check forgetting that the piece that's
delivering the check is blocking
a formerly controlled diagonal
that's a twisted way of saying that the
queen controls g7 and after knight f6
you relinquish that control but the mate
here is 97 this is a double check
and it's a mate because the queen
controls all of the king's possible
escape squares
this is very win-ish
okay
simple game but i think a good start to
the speed run let's have a quick look
um
yeah my opponent played fast which is
going to be pretty common at this level
i faced this move once in my career
uh when i was 1600 that game ended in
the only smothered mate i've ever
delivered in my
in my chess career
okay one second
yeah um i delivered smothered mate for
the first time in my chess career and
the only time thank you tom hawker
so knight c3 we develop our piece
c6 is probably not such a bad move
because it controls the d5 square
um just a little note that after knight
c6
i think a lot of people here
would instantly go knight d5
centralizing the knight attacking the
queen and the pawn
one little thing i'm going to say
as we just get started is that
you know one move itis is i think plays
a much bigger role in the beginner's
thinking patterns than i previously
thought
because even up until 15 1600 i find
that people
they see a move that creates a threat
and sometimes two threats
and their thinking stops there because
you feel like just by doing that you're
you're making improvements that's
very often not the case now here 95 is
actually not as impressive as it may
appear it's not a bad move
it's not a bad move by any means but
it's maybe not the best move
the reason why is that now black is
going to get the knight out to f6
and then black is going to offer a
nitrate and you've just moved your
knight twice
and you might very well have to either
acquiesce to a trade or retreat it back
to c3
so in this position i would play the
much simpler bishop c4 just continuing
my development and potentially even d3
okay so c6 now we open up the center
now is a great time because black has
nothing developed
yeah bishop g5 by the way was also a
possible move just developing the bishop
and hitting the queen
but no reason to to be fancy
bishop e3 bishop c4
knight h6 aiming for g4 so we prevent
that now i just want to briefly explain
why the move f3
where does ben feingold's statement
actually come from what is the science
behind f3 often being bad because we all
know that he's right we joke about it
but f3 often is a
very big weakening move whereas
something like g3
which intuitively would seem to weaken
more squares isn't talked about in the
same way
well there's two reasons first is that
f3 unlike g3 is oftentimes a tempting
move for beginners because it does a
couple of different things it gives a
sense of comfort i think it builds up a
pawn chain it defends g4 it does
accomplish a lot
the problem is that this diagonal that i
indicated with one arrow
and this with the other arrow are two of
the most high trafficked diagonals on
the board
uh that means a lot is going on there
think about how often you develop your
bishop to c4 bishop to c5 how often a
queen goes to b3 or a queen to b6 pretty
darn often
and in my opinion one of the biggest
reasons f3 is so dangerous that it
creates weaknesses along that diagonal
your king is often on g1 so you're often
going to get pinned or there's going to
be something that becomes undefended
such as the bishop
and this undefended piece on e3 is
another big deal because if your
opponent has a rook on e8
anytime the e-file opens whatever stands
there is going to be weak
and presumably your d-pod has already
moved away
so
even though it doesn't weaken as many
squares mathematically as a move like g3
it creates long-term weaknesses that are
very likely to
be exploitable in the course of the game
so that's very abstract but
maybe that helps you put things into
context a little bit and that's why
what you'll see me doing is often
playing h3 in favor of f3 when i need to
develop defend the g4 square okay so
queen d2
and last thing really to talk about
because you know once the c6 pawn was
blundered the game basically ended
is that there is a
tactic here
you always have to watch for this tactic
when your opponent hasn't developed
their queen side at all
uh
this is a particular type of
idea that needs to be looked for
uh
things that bring it on include a lead
in development because it's likelier to
to happen or sometimes if the queen is
out early it can trigger this type of
tactic
who sees it
yeah so this rook has no square so if
you put a bishop on this diagonal it's
going to trap the rook
takes
takes and bishop d5 and the important
thing is that black cannot even get in
exchange for that rook the bishop is
going to return home scot-free
but one of the most important rules of
calculation is that you never assume
that a move is forced unless it actually
is
you need to pause on every move and ask
yourself whether your opponent might not
have
hidden resources and if you look very
carefully black i think has two
resources that complicate the game i'm
not sure that they necessarily work
the first is bishop a6 it pins the
knight to the bishop
because i noticed that the bishop on c4
is unprotected the second is the move d5
trying to plug the hole with a white
pawn and then take on b5
so complexity arises out of these
positions where lots of stuff is hanging
white probably should go bishop b3 here
to preserve the ability to take on d5 of
the bishop but why complicate things
when we can just
when we can just castle
or we could just drop the bishop
um
so that why not id takes b5
yeah similar reason i mean take stakes
and bishop a6
uh but maybe this was the computer
recommendation i don't really
i don't really know but all of this for
a pawn is is a little bit absurd
uh so that's a a rule of thumb that i'll
i'll end with here if you're trying to
work out these long lines you're not
sure about whether to grab a pawn when
in doubt don't grab it because at your
like the level of beginners even
intermediate players pawns are not going
to determine the result of the game it's
a it's not a common reason that somebody
lost oh i lost the pawn then you traded
all of the pieces and then i lost the
game that happens of course but it's
rare
and so don't concern yourself too much
if you're unsure
about whether you can get away with
grabbing a pawn it's often not worth
calculating not worth spending a lot of
time on
uh it's the sort of thing you either do
it
quickly or not at all
uh and once
once knight a6 was played see i didn't
even see that this pawn was hanging but
we saw it on the next move we
centralized the knight this is a great
example of that not bothering to grab
the second pawn but prioritizing piece
placement instead and centralizing the
knight
and that's it 97 we win the queen and we
win the game
what about taking the knight with the
bishop to mess up the pawn structure
yeah so
this would be tempting for a lot of
players
the problem with this move is that it
leads to a queen trade in order to ruin
your opponent's spawn structure you have
to trade queens and then you've kind of
defeated the purpose of ruining the
kingside pawn stroke of course white is
much better but i could already smell
blood and so keeping the queens on the
board made more sense
um
yeah when we get to a stronger level
i'll i'll start redefining the way that
you should look at things including
pawns
but hopefully that was an adequate
first game
welcome to edition three
and we will continue this in future
streams but i'm gonna head out i have to
i have to go i know this was a short one
but
hopefully it was sweet
bye everybody
[Music]